video games have tried a lot of silly
things to enhance shooters over the
years some like nintendo's humble rumble
pack and the haptic feedback and
controllers they would inspire have
stood the test of time and others like
this
not so much let's jump into some of the
silliest ideas video games have tried
that just didn't quite work out in their
own time hit that subscribe button give
us the old thumbs up let's get to it
if you were around in the late 1900s
specifically 1992 you probably watched
lawnmower man or read the book snow
crash and you were sold that all your
video games and possibly your entire
life would become part of virtual
reality very soon this was 100 the way
of the future and to sell that point
home malls all over the country set up
these kiosks where you could put on this
massive headset and play dactyl
nightmare it was a very simple pvp arena
shooter where you walked around lobbing
projectiles at other players teleporting
around the map and trying not to get
yeaded off a map by a dinosaur it's not
that vr was a bad idea in the 90s it's
just that we all thought these things
would be in our lives at that time and
that was laughable because the tech
wasn't nearly small enough or affordable
enough for that to happen for something
like 30 more years the cost was way too
high and computers weren't nearly strong
enough to bring that technology home
seriously at that time computers looked
like this
it just wasn't going to work then and to
be honest vr's still in pretty early
stages now
we all used to have crt televisions that
were ridiculously heavy and tough to
move around and apparently had a high
voltage capacitor inside that could kill
you if you took it apart even when it
was unplugged but it was totally worth
all the hassle to play light gun games
there were some great ones like duck
hunt a launch game for nes in 1985 and
my absolute favorite time crisis
then one day i remember walking into a
best buy and seeing my first flat screen
tv it looked like some kind of space
magic and cost about as much as space
magic would at something like 10 000
i had no idea what i was really looking
at was the end of light gun games at
home as people bought these tvs
accessories like the nes zapper and gun
cons for ps2 simply stopped working so
it turns out crt televisions allow for
more precise measurement of where a
light gun was pointing at the screen the
details are a bit complicated so i'll
link some videos below light gun games
didn't instantly give up and disappear
it was more of a slow death and it
wasn't for developers lack of trying to
keep them alive consoles like the wii
xbox 360 and playstation 3 all tried to
carry on using a sensor bar that was
placed on top or just below a television
but the way it behaved was more like
dragging a cursor around your television
screen it was never very precise or
satisfying the likes that consoles
continued after that to experiment in
order to track your aim led to some even
funnier inventions like the ps3's rave
stick looking playstation move
controller that you could use with
killzone 3. now according to one linus
tech tips that technology may have just
finally caught up to flat screen
televisions so light gun games could
make a return
[Music]
oh boy the kinect for xbox 360 and xbox
one i need to start off by saying i'm
probably one of the few people who loves
present tense connect and i still use it
to this day for exercise games it was
there for me with hand gestures and
voice commands when i was elbow deep in
my kids diapers and couldn't exactly
touch things
and a huge source of relief early in the
pandemic when we couldn't leave the
house but still needed outlets for
movement
connect tried a lot of things and i love
that developers were really grappling
with the technology it was great for all
kinds of things like dancing
but boy did it not work out for shooters
for technical and also kind of creepy
reasons on the technical side when it
comes to shooters the kinect just
doesn't work it was one thing in the
past to be holding a fake toy gun but
now you were standing there with nothing
in your hands just completely imagining
a weapon or something sometimes you even
had to pretend you were a weapon it was
just really goofy for all parties
involved the most memorable attempt was
ghost recon future soldier using connect
to aim and shoot weapons as well as
navigate their gunsmith you had to take
this kind of awkward horse stance aim
with a fist and then quickly open and
close your hand on the screen to fire it
to be fair this did lead to a pretty
great trailer with coco ice-t's special
someone who awkwardly showed off this
mechanic and generally looked like she
could kill a man so i'll probably stop
talking now there were some other
creative attempts that sort of worked
like gunstringer where you control the
marionette and use your fingers to shoot
my kids had a pretty hard time with the
hand-eye coordination for that one
because the game was legit hard other
than that there were some hunting games
and
black water
oh boy
so remember how people with tin foil
hats always say the government's
watching you like they have eyes
everywhere
well microsoft came out with an
always-on living room camera with the
kinect around the time it came out that
the nsa was actually collecting data and
watching pretty much all americans like
granny on down
that royally creeped people out and they
did not want a camera with a microphone
staring at them in their living room all
the time
especially when they might be playing
games like mass effect 3 and screaming
hey shoot that guy it's interesting
because iphones were becoming popular
around the same time
and nowadays people carry around cell
phones all the time or have alexa in
their home listening to them and both of
those are far more powerful at
surveillance
[Music]
voice commands in a tactical navy seal
inspired game made a ton of sense on
paper but my roommates at school
probably thought i was not sitting in my
room screaming tactical commands at my
tv like breach bang clear socom us navy
seals came with a mostly functional mic
and headset that you could use to talk
to your ai teammates but you couldn't
just say whatever you wanted you had to
follow a specific line of commands that
your squadmates could understand and
that didn't exactly flow naturally or
work under pressure particularly in an
unforgiving milsim game the voice
commands can be really frustrating i
lost track of the number of times ai
teammates would do unexpected things
like listen to me intently and then run
over to a live grenade on the ground
like a golden retriever or throw a
flashbang right into a door frame and
back into our team it was hard to
remember how to tell your team to get
away from dangerous spots when all you
wanted to scream was get the hell away
from there even though voice commands
didn't really work well the general idea
again was ahead of its time and probably
was about as good as early
text-to-speech software think of how
many devices you talk to now i mean this
one could come back in future games it
could be really interesting to have much
more natural conversations with your ai
squad mates assuming the other people in
your real life don't mind you screaming
at televisions
[Music]
one of the hands down best inventions in
all of games is a controller rumbler a
dead simple haptic device inside of your
controller that vibrates and gives you
feedback through your hands so it makes
sense that some developers wanted to try
to apply this rumbling sensation to
other parts of your body but just
because you can doesn't mean you should
for starters a lot of them aren't taking
input from the games themselves but just
listening to sound and responding to the
audio input the feedback from getting
hit basically seems to boil down to a
locational massage and in one case a
reviewer tried a touching simulator
which got really awkward really weird
okay can you get off me alright can you
stop touching down there please can you
stop you need to learn boundaries if
you're using add-ons like head
attachments then when you play a game
you're basically getting kicked in the
head and the entire point of games
particularly shooters is to take the fun
and stimulating parts of the combat and
leave behind the traumatic parts like
pain to be fair some reviewers seem to
like the butt focus haptic feedback and
things like racing games that let you
feel the engine rumble strips and
anti-lock brakes but you're basically
just sitting on a base speaker at that
point so maybe just scoot your base
speaker on a little closer first and try
that haptic gloves on the other hand are
pretty cool i tried out the white falcon
haptic controller at ces many years ago
and i could genuinely feel the different
textures of digital objects but this
technology has not caught on to
mainstream gaming and at the same time
the humble rubble controller keeps just
getting more and more advanced see the
ps5 dual sense honestly if you play with
a haptic vest i would love to know more
and please tell me what you think below
[Music]
what wacky things you remember shooters
trying over the years that didn't work
or were just too far ahead of their time
we have a bunch more shooter focused
list videos coming soon so head on over
to gamespot's youtube page to check out
8 great sniping games you can play now
thanks for watching
[Music]
you